classical conditioning is a way of
learning where a stimulus that triggers
a biological response is paired with a
new stimulus that then results in the
same reaction
the most famous work in classical
conditioning was done by Ivan Pavlov in
the 1890s during this time Pavlov did a
lot of research around the digestive
processes of dogs one day during his
research Pavlov noticed that the dogs
began to salivate in the presence of the
technician who normally fed them he
wondered if the technician was a trigger
that stimulated a response associated
with food to find out he constructed an
experiment that would allow him to
measure a dog's output of saliva first
he served the dog food then he served
food while playing the sounds of a
metronome and repeated the process a few
times
finally he removed the food and only
played the metronome the dogs began to
salivate in response to the metronome
alone Pavlov concluded that if a new
stimulus was present when the dog was
given food then that stimulus became
associated with food and cost salivation
on its own
when he published his findings Pavlov
called the food an unconditioned
stimulus because its effects on the dog
were not learned instead they triggered
an unconditioned response that happened
naturally and completely out of the
dog's control the metronome is at first
a neutral stimulus through the process
of repetitive pairing with food the dog
learns to connect the two this means
that the neutral stimulus becomes the
conditioned stimulus and the response to
that a conditioned response he also
reported that one learning occurred most
rapidly when the interval between the
sound and the appearance of the food was
short to the saliva produced by the
sound differed in composition from that
produced by the food which means that
the conditioned response was not an
exact replica of the unconditioned
response 3 while there are several forms
of conditioning such as forward and
backward conditioning classical
conditioning cannot create new behavior
or be used for training but instead
triggers involuntary biological
responses for we can almost entirely
undo the conditioning this happens
through extinction when we repeatedly
present the conditioned stimulus in the
absence of the unconditioned stimulus
so what occurs inside the brain when a
dog sees the food the signals from the
eyes and nose stimulate the brain which
activates the salivation glands to
secrete saliva to aid the dog with the
digestion when a dog hears a sound the
ears send a signal to the brain which
takes note but has no reason to activate
anything when the two different
neurological processes are being
activated simultaneously new synaptic
connections occur between the auditory
stimulus and the behavioral response
over time these synapses are
strengthened so that it only takes the
sound to activate the pathway leading to
salivation
you can try this popular classroom
exercise take a friend sit down and
relax for two minutes then allow your
partner to check and record your pulse
rate your partner will then tap a pencil
on the desk five times right after stand
up and hop on one leg for 30 seconds and
then check your pulse again repeat the
procedure four times having the partner
record all data after relaxing for the
fifth time your partner will tap the
pencil five times as usual now instead
of getting up for your exercise only
check your pulse
if the conditioning was successful your
pulse rate will rise even without
engaging in exercise
what do you think does classical
conditioning always work if so are
commercials a form of mental
manipulation and should we limit
advertising in public spaces
you
sprouts videos are published under the
Creative Commons license that means our
videos are free and anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools governments and nonprofit
organizations can also use them for
training online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute just visit patreon.com slash
sprouts even one dollar can make a
difference if you have deep insights
into academic topics and want to help us
explain complicated ideas and simple
language please contact us at sprouts
schools comm
you